as we start the week let's take a look
at bitcoin price bitcoin at around 62
000
up about 1.4
or so s p gold silver euro yen rendon b
and oil all trash assets in comparison
because when fiscal monetary policy is
out of control people need a store of
value that protects their purchasing
power and that is exactly what we're
watching happen with bitcoin if we go
ahead and we look at the individual
stats of the network 1.16
trillion dollar market cap very very
high and growing the inflation rate 1.78
there's 89
of the supply that is in circulation
about 10 billion dollars was settled on
chain in the last 24 hours one of my
favorite statistics is what is that
mining reward value the bitcoin miners
were paid 56.2 million over the last 24
hours to secure the network the bitcoin
network is the most decentralized secure
largest most powerful computer network
in the world and that 56 million dollars
getting paid up to the miners is a big
part of it we are now about four to five
percent off of the all-time high
all-time highs around 64
800 or so and my guess is that we are
going to break that shortly
is it going to happen during the show is
it going to happen tomorrow it's going
to happen this week we will find out if
we go ahead and we look at the return on
investment with bitcoin you can see that
it's up 418 over the last year or so
what's very interesting is right around
this point
four years ago people are now up about a
thousand percent depending on when we
screenshot this exactly and so if you
had bought bitcoin on this day in 2017's
bull market and you held it and wrote it
through that 80 plus percent drawdown
and all the volatility along the way you
now would be up about 1 000
or 10x if you bought gold last year
you've literally lost 7 on a nominal
basis and you are down double digits on
a real return basis if we then go ahead
and we look at bitcoin versus the other
select indexes and assets you can see
that bitcoin is compound annual growth
rate that's cagr right there compound
annual growth rate over the last decade
has been 170
absolute astronomical performance for
the digital currency now when we start
to look at these statistics most of this
is looking backwards but what is very
interesting is there are tons of signs
that suggest that bitcoin is about to go
parabolic now what do i mean by that you
can look at the actual market structure
you can look at the on-chain metrics and
ask yourself what is this setting up for
we first look at the actual number of
bitcoin that are on exchanges we can see
that from 2012 or so the number of
bitcoin on exchanges has drastically
dropped that's that yellow line that's
falling from the sky we then have kind
of oscillated there and continued to
remain at very low levels for quite a
while but what you can see is that since
september or so
uh or i'm sorry since september you can
see that we've been down here around
these all-time lows now over the weekend
we saw a slight drop right there at the
end you can see that slight drop in the
actual number of bitcoin that are on
exchanges as you can see usually when
that occurs there is an increase in
price why if there's tons of bitcoin
sitting on exchanges it's very easy to
sell it it creates selling pressure on
the price but if people are going onto
exchanges they're buying bitcoin they
then take it off of the exchange and so
the number of bitcoin on exchanges or
the exchange balance is going down that
suggests that there is more long-term
holders and therefore increases in
demand lead to an increase in price and
so very positive to see that we are
remaining somewhere near those all-time
lows from when it comes to exchange
balance
on top of that this morning from
charles edwards we got this tweet that
suggested that the mvrv z score has
reclaimed three now for those that don't
know mvrv z score is essentially the
difference between the total market cap
and the realized market cap total market
cap simply takes the number of
outstanding bitcoin times the price per
bitcoin that's what you see in that 1.16
trillion dollar market cap but what the
realized cap is it looks at when was the
last time that this bitcoin actually
traded hands and what was the price at
that moment so if i last sold a bitcoin
let's say to joseph at one thousand
dollars that would count as one thousand
dollars towards the realized cap versus
the 62 000 that it would count towards
the market cap and so when you look at
the difference between the total market
cap and the realized market cap and then
you divide it by the standard deviation
of the market cap you can score it what
we know is that when we cross over three
it usually leads to a drastic increase
in price and we just reclaimed that
three there and so when we see these
types of movements there usually ends up
being a market structure that has a very
bullish story behind it but last but not
least dylan leclair coming out and
showing that the long-term holders are
still in accumulation mode even though
85 of bitcoin has not moved in the last
90 days long-term holders are still
buying more and he said that typically
we see these during bear markets or
consolidation periods but instead we are
watching this happen as bitcoin's price
has doubled over the last couple of
months from 30 000 now up over 60 000
so to see those long-term holders
continuing to accumulate into price
strength like this is very very bullish
and so when we start to look at what is
actually occurring in the market and
because of the on-chain metrics and that
open transparent ledger that bitcoin
provides we can see that not only has
bitcoin been very strong over the last
10 years over the last year but also the
market structure and the setup is very
interesting now on top of that we've got
the bitcoin etf coming we're going to
talk about that later in the show but
also right before the show started
interactive brokers announced that they
are going to allow for registered
investment advisors rias think of these
as more financial advisors they are
going to allow them now to buy bitcoin
and cryptocurrencies via their
traditional platform
what this does is it allows for every
registered investment advisor in the
united states using that interactive
broker's platform to start to give their
clients exposure
john how many different rias are there
in the country and do we know how much
assets they have yeah it's just under
fourteen thousand like thirteen five
hundred and then was it the aum of them
is a hundred and ten trillion in
like 61 million clients so if we talk
about 65 million clients with a hundred
plus trillion dollars in assets that are
managed by about 14 000 registered
investment
advisors interactive brokers just opened
the floodgates and said you now have the
opportunity to get those assets that 110
trillion dollars or so into the bitcoin
or cryptocurrency market if those
advisors choose to simply just move one
percent about 1.1 trillion dollars into
bitcoin that would be double the market
cap of the asset today so we would go
from the 1.1 trillion we already have
plus 1.1 trillion from the rias and
therefore you'd have a 2.2 trillion
dollar market cap the amount of wealth
that is held by rias is absolutely
insane and when we look at the market
structure the fact that it's a highly
eliquid asset with 85 not having moved
in the last 90 days and then the mvrv
z-score going over three
it becomes a very very explosive
situation
you have a similar situation to what you
had back in 2020 you've got supply that
nobody wants to sell but you have
increasing demand not only do you have
increasing demand because of the macro
environment and sustained levels of over
five percent inflation but you also have
increased access points people who have
had high demand for the asset but
they've struggled to get exposure
previously now they can use etfs now
they can also use the interactive
brokers platform from rias and you put
all that demand into an illiquid supply
and it is likely to lead to a very high
price increase now history does not mean
that that is a signal for what's going
to happen in the future there's risk
with all of this but i like to see this
type of market structure this type of
increasing demand with this type of
illiquid asset and so just as we've been
talking about four weeks now q4
historically has turned out to be very
positive in bull markets for bitcoin's
asset but
when you start to add in all of these
other factors not only having the q4
situation but also increase assets and
the illiquid supply my guess is that we
are going to see absolute rocket fuel
point poured
on one of the best performing assets in
the world